♪ -Tonight Show
Dance Battle, yeah ♪
-Here is the dance move
generator.
We're going to take turns
hitting this button,
which will randomly select
a never-before-seen dance move.
Whoever's turn it is has to make
up a dance for that move,
and the best dancer wins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Heidi, since you're the guest,
why don't you go first?
Let's start
the dance move generator.
When you're ready.
Invisible hula hoop.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That should be a dance.
Roots, can we get a beat?
♪♪
Hey, whoa, hey, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, hey, whoa!
Whoa!
Hey!
Oh, my goodness!
Come on. Who does it better
than Heidi Klum?
That should be a dance.
Do I have to -- Do I have to go?
Judges? Judges?
Boy, that was fantastic.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, that was a --
Yeah, I remember.
All right. Now it's my turn.
I can't top that.
Let's start the generator here.
Give me invisible hula hoop.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How do I get that and she gets
to do the hula hoop?
-I like that.
-Fork in the garbage disposal.
Am I the fork or am I --
-Yes.
-So, am I the --
All right, I got it.
Fork in the garbage disposal.
Okay, gotcha.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
The first thing, putting
the fork in, then I became --
I became the fork...
-I saw that.
-...in front of your eyes
like magic.
-I saw that. it was good.
It was good.
-I'm the David Blaine of dance.
-Do I have another shot?
-Yes, you do. Of course.
Let's start
the dance battle generator.
-I'll have to try harder now.
-There you go.
-Speed bowling.
-I-I-I don't know
how this is a dance.
Speed bowling --
You have to bowl very fast.
-The good thing is
I brought my bowling balls.
♪♪
-Oh, hey, whoa.
All right, yeah.
Heidi, that way.
The pins are that way.
Heidi, hey, whoa! Heidi, Heidi!
Heidi, all right, that's enough.
Hey, you got it!
You got a strike.
That's it, speed bowling.
No, no, please, Heidi!
We got that strike. Let's go.
We got the score.
You got a -- You got a --
Trust me.
You got a perfect game.
You got a 300. Oh, my goodness.
[ Laughter ]
Are we still on the air?
Okay. Perfect.
-I'm very competitive.
-Dance generator,
let's see what you've got.
Gosh.
What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't wait to see that one.
-Mom tries --
Mom tries hip-hop.
-She's cool. She's a cool mom.
-A cool mom.
Yeah, sure. Yeah.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
She started off a little shy,
and then Mom started doing
Stanky leg.
And that's what changed
the whole thing around.
-I don't know about that one.
-Surely I know
after I tried that one.
No, clearly, you're the better
dancer -- Heidi Klum, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why even -- Why even compete
against each other
when we can dance together?
-Okay.
-Will you?
-Yes.
-All right, let's do it.
Dance battle generator.
Would you like to do it?
-Yes.
Push it together?
-Sure.
-Okay. Eggs and bacon.
-We can do this.
-Since you have the eggs,
I'll be the bacon.
[ Laughter ]
I'll be the bacon,
and you be the eggs.
-But you -- Okay.
-You have eggs. I'm the bacon.
-You are the grand slam.
Yes. All right.
I'll do the eggs.
All right. Eggs.
I'm on the eggs
and you're on the bacon.
All right, gotcha.
This is eggs and bacon.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is all the time we have for
"Tonight Show" Dance Battle!
Heidi Klum!
There you go. They love you.
More with Heidi Klum
when we come back, everybody.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]